McKinley okay again
Keep standing here but this weekendOnly cuz
you're 70 I was about to get up anyway.
S
I don't know you still got 4 years you might
you might not
If
SuperI'm looking right there.
Yeah
YeahI'm awake.
Girl tomorrow morning Saturday Sunday
morning
Today's Friday yeah today is Saturday
The
Daughter Church
Frozen
Yes
I couldn't remember
We'll sleep
CarmenI need you to wake me up in 2 hours I
got to go to work. You heard me or no why
are you questioning it.
I had to go to work at 10:00 so I need to be
up by 9:30
Hello openOkay okay.
Hope you feel better
Yeah 9:30
Like what is the point in asking you to wake
me up
Pretty sure he's
Did you come down at 9:30 or 9:30 did he
tell you come back upstairs
Okay then you're the devil you didn't come
down here at 9:30 just accept it don't say
anything
Dumbass ideas
Oh yeah
Oh yeah in the situation where I got 2
minutes to fucking sleep they come in here
and start arguing over dumb ass shit
Call me up cuz y'all that much that mother
fucking home
Situation around 2 hours
I'm glad you're stupid